this is the Razer Blade 16 arguably one
of the best Windows laptops out there
and this is the M2 Max MacBook Pro 16
inch and in this video we're gonna see
if the Razer can destroy the Apple
MacBook Pro with the latest silicon and
to do that we're going to be testing
everything we're going to talk a little
bit about the designs the keyboards
track pads the webcams the speakers but
mainly about the performance of the ssds
the CPU GPU everything and real world
performance to see which one is the
better value because this razor is
actually a hundred dollars more
expensive than the MacBook Pro with the
same specs yes one terabyte of SSD 32
gigs of RAM six units display same specs
now let's get right into it starting
with the build quality the hand is
definitely nice on the Razer getting
really close to how good it is on the
MacBook we've got cnc'd aluminum on both
of these We have basically a matte black
which looks absolutely awesome however
when you do open it up you can
definitely start to see those
fingerprints whereas the MacBook is a
lot more fingerprint resistant this
thing has Windows hello which is awesome
much better than Touch ID on the MacBook
in terms of portability the MacBook Pro
is definitely a lot Slimmer than this
thick boy razor and that's because it's
packing some crazy power in terms of the
13th gen I9 chip and RTX 4080 GPU and
that unfortunately means that you have
to have this massive 330 watt gean power
supply which is insane it needs it for
all of that power that the GPU and CPU
take whereas the MacBook just has a 140
watt power brick now testing out the
keyboard I'm actually really impressed
with how this feels this feels a lot
better than the MSI Raider laptop feels
nice and clicky really liking the
response very similar to how the MacBook
feels almost looks like we have a little
bit more key travel on this razor so I'm
very happy about that however I can't
stand this track pad this is just
garbage diving board design which means
the top is impossible to click and as
you get lower it gets easier and easier
and that just annoys the crap out of me
I always mess up the left clicks and
right clicks it just doesn't work good
compared to the force touch track pad on
the MacBook Pro absolutely incredible
anywhere you click you get a perfect
response because this is actually a
solid state track pad not a physical one
so it works amazing so overall design
and build quality wise the MacBook Pro
definitely takes the cake with the slim
design the portability the much better
trackpad overall this thing takes the
cake and now I want to test out the
speakers to see which one is going to
offer the better movie or show watching
experience
[Music]
holy moly guys that was a massive
massive difference so I was listening to
the Razer Blade 16. it sounded pretty
good the vocals the highs pretty decent
the bass wasn't really there and then I
turned on the MacBook Pro and it blew my
mind I don't know if you saw me I was
dancing to that because the bass is just
massive it's so nice and deep it's
actually there compared to the razor
where it's basically non-existent now
another thing I'm noticing right now
even with this open is the difference in
display quality looking at the MacBook
Pro the blacks are actually black
compared to the Razer it is flat and
gray now it does look like it has an
anti-reflectivity kind of matte texture
coating so it's not as reflective yet I
can actually see myself more on the
MacBook Pro so that's a good point for
the Razer however everything is great
now one reason for that might be because
this supports 240 hertz Ultra fast
refresh rate which is really good
compared to Pro motion that goes up to
120 so two times better and of course
this is meant to be a gaming laptop so
definitely props for that but the
quality is just garbage compared to the
MacBook Pro now on top of that the
resolution is 2.5 k on this thing 16
inch compared to 3.5 K almost 4k on the
16 inch MacBook Pro so you're getting
even sharper resolution as well and then
of course the panel itself is basically
srgb standard definition compared to
mini LED a lot better with up to 1600
nits of peak brightness and now let's
compare the webcam and mic quality on
the MacBook Pro first as you can see so
let me know your thoughts on how it
sounds how it looks the detail the noise
levels are is my hair crushed at all and
now let's switch over to the razor
alright this right here is the Razer
Blade 16 and even right here I can see
the quality is definitely not as good my
hair is kind of like blacked out but you
guys let me know how the microphone
sounds and how it actually compares to
the MacBook Pro in terms of video
quality as well down below and now let's
get into performance but first if you're
a Mac or Windows user who does any sort
of work with documents spreadsheets or
slideshows our sponsor software keep is
giving our viewers 25 off on genuine
Microsoft software like a one-time
purchase of Microsoft Office for Mac or
Windows which includes word excel and
PowerPoint now there are so many fishy
websites out there that could scam you
but software keep is a Microsoft
certified partner who sells only 100
genuine Microsoft software so you don't
have to worry which resulted in software
keep earning over a hundred thousand
five star reviews they also have great
prices on other software including the
most popular antivirus software out
there and their customer service is
phenomenal with 24 7 365 customer
support where you'll talk to a real
person instead of a robot so if you have
any questions they'll be glad to help so
buy Microsoft Office for Mac windows or
anything else you need today and save 25
off their already great prices by using
the link in the description and the
coupon code
mtyt25 and now let's jump into the
actual performance starting off with the
speed of the SSD so I'm going to go
ahead and run this test now I do want to
mention they both have one terabyte ssds
so let's see which one's faster alright
we have our results and this is quite
interesting the Razer is faster in the
read speed 60 800 compared to 64.80 on
the MacBook Pro but the macbook's
actually faster in terms of right
7169 compared to 4 800. now where it
gets weird is the random writes and
reads where this thing is on a whole
nother level 3
000 4K right compared to a thousand that
is just crazy high I don't even know if
this is running properly or not but
based on this the Razer is beating it in
those scores and now let's get into
running geekbench six the new one that
just came out that's optimized for real
world workflows of 2023 and Beyond now
we can see the frequencies 3.68 base
frequency on the M2 Max compared to a
base of 2.2 which of course gets much
higher on the I9 3950h Max that we have
here this is actually a 24 core chip
compared to 12 so double the cores and
of course both of these have 32 gigs of
RAM so let's go ahead and run the
Benchmark and wow would you look at
those scores the Razer laptop is
actually beating the MacBook in terms of
single core performance thus 31
faster that is seriously impressive
however the 12 core M2 Max is beating
the 24 core I9 chip by 10 in terms of
multi-core performance now the reason
for that is because geekbench 6 is now
optimized to be more realistic so
instead of repeating the same tasks each
time for each core that you have so 24
of an identical task it's running one
big task across all of the cores so you
have diminishing returns with tons of
cores like 24 on this machine so the M2
Max is doing better and now in terms of
real world kind of single core
performance and web browsing snappiness
I want to run speedometer 2.1 to see
kind of how the performance for web
browsing is going to be on each of these
wow this is actually impressive 13 gen
Intel is killing at 395 I think that's
the highest score I've ever seen a
Windows machine get on speedometer of
course the M2 Max actually did Beat It
by about 11 so still better probably
because it's better optimized with
webcam and everything else but this is
super impressive web browsing and now
let's test out web design performance
using figma and this right here is a
project provided to us by an LA based
web design studio 500 designs which is
awesome so what we're going to do right
here is basically just zoom in on some
of these pages to see how fast the
response time is on each machine so
let's go ahead zoom in
you could see there you go it just took
a second or two and now it's nice and
crisp let's try it out on the MacBook
Pro
okay zooming in
and up there you go so it seems pretty
similar in terms of performance Let's
test out another area okay I'm gonna
zoom in right here right on her face and
there you go just took a second now it's
nice and sharp and now on the Razer
it did take a little bit longer on the
razor but let's go ahead and do an
export test to see which one wins and
well already just 20 seconds in the fans
are kicking up very very loud and there
you go the razors finished one minute
and 35 seconds the M2 Max MacBook Pro
finish in exactly the same time a minute
and 35 seconds so that is insane the
same exact time for web design this
right here I'm excited about because
geekbench 6 finally fixed the metal GPU
test in terms of optimization so now
it's finally running properly so let's
run it on both of these Vulcan on the
Razer with the 4080 laptop GPU let's see
how this Compares of course we're
plugged in on this machine all right and
it looks like something's going wrong
with the Razer because we're only
getting 9600 points compared to 138
000 so I did check all the power
settings you can see I don't have low
power mode anything on I have it on best
performance everything that I've checked
is best performance so this is weird I'm
gonna go ahead and run the opencl
version and there you go that is a
proper score 168
000 opencl with the 4080 laptop GPU
that's about 21 faster than the M2 Max
with the best 38 core GPU and now since
geekbench 6 is more of a raw GPU
performance Benchmark let's take it into
a little bit more of a real world
scenario with Wildlife extreme unlimited
from 3D Mark which is going to give us a
realistic view of the actual gaming FPS
performance and now we have our scores
looking at the Razer we have
189.25 FPS compared to
151.2 so now it's about 25 faster than
the MacBook Pro even better than using
geekbench 6. so this thing is going to
be a gaming Beast while the Macbook Pro
not so much because this type of
performance you're only going to see in
fully optimized Games like World of
Warcraft and a lot of the other games
where you have to use crossover
translation or Rosetta everything else
it is not going to perform this well so
for gaming this thing is definitely much
better but now let's get into really
stress testing the CPU with cinebench
R23 this is gonna be a 10 minute stress
test let's go ahead and turn on the
multi-core test and I do have both MX
power Gadget and Intel power Gadget
running side by side we can see we have
57 Watts package power right now on the
Intel chip frequency sitting at 2.1
gigahertz it did Spike up though so
overall this thing is definitely using a
lot more power 5657 compared to 34
package power are on the M2 Max now the
interesting thing is that the
temperature is heating up faster on the
M2 Max about 91 degrees celsius compared
to about 64 interestingly only on the
razor with the Intel chip this thing is
absolutely blazing through this test all
right and the test is finished and it
looks like we have 17 307 points on the
Razer 13
633 on the M2 Max making the Intel chip
faster in cinnamon so it's keeping the
multi-core crown compared to the Apple
MacBook Pro which Apple silicon still
cannot keep up at least in laptops
compared to these Intel chips so I've
got to say Bravo 24 cores doing very
well still can't keep up but can this
apply in the real world well let's find
out here we are in Lightroom Classic
this is a test we do a lot exporting 50
42 megapixel Raw photos so let's do that
on both of these machines and go all
right they're both exporting right now
all right the MacBook Pro finished in 41
seconds and for some reason this thing
just stalled out a couple times I don't
know what's going on now it's not
responding now it's not closing this is
the reason why people buy Max instead of
Windows laptops all right let's go ahead
and give this another go let's see how
fast it is and there you go it finished
in one minute in two seconds so 41
seconds on the MacBook Pro a minute and
two so it took 21 seconds longer
basically 50 longer on the Razer with
this 13th gen I9 compared to the M2 Max
so it looks like in the real world the
MacBook Pro is quite a lot faster even
though it doesn't look like it in terms
of losing with cinebench R23 and now
let's go ahead and test out blender 3D
rendering which Windows laptops like
this are killer ad because this 4080
laptop GPU has Ray tracing cores that
kill it and it has the Opti X which I
have selected so let's go ahead and
Export the party tug image whoa that was
fast okay 3.3 seconds on the razor
4.6 on the M2 Max actually not that far
behind all right we gotta test out
something a little bit longer like BMW
all right we got BMW going right here on
both of them all right now this was
absolutely insane the Razer finish in
just above six seconds compared to
21.8 on the M2 Max this is why you buy
Windows laptops with Nvidia gpus for 3D
rendering Apple just can't compete at
least until blender will be fully
rebuilt and optimized for metal three
we'll see when that happens but not
right now now with all that said let me
tell you guys which one I think is the
winner and I'm gonna be honest right
here the Razer is a hundred dollars more
expensive than the MacBook Pro but the
MacBook Pro does offer a couple of
advantages it's kind of higher quality
overall so you got the better more slim
profile design better portability you
have better speakers better track pad
better display quality better webcam so
the overall build and design is better
on the MacBook Pro basically giving you
a better experience while the Razer is
first of all bigger it's thicker it's
louder with the fans the display is
definitely not as nice in terms of the
quality the webcam is not as good
speakers are nowhere near as good but
you do have 240 hertz in terms of the
display which matches up to the 4080
laptop GPU so you get a killer gaming
experience with this laptop I would
definitely recommend it for gaming and
you also get an absolutely killer 3D
ring rendering machine and overall in
terms of performance this thing is the
winner however there were a couple of
cases where the MacBook Pro was faster
like for CPU performance and Lightroom
classic photo exporting this one did
beat it out and I think that's because
of the unified memory architecture that
is overall more efficient and of course
it doesn't have to be plugged in like
this thing which is a mobile desktop so
better experience with the MacBook Pro
much better performance with the Razer
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below and if you enjoyed
this video click the circle above to
subscribe for more like this one thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
thank you